Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Dr. Gloria Mark, who's the chancellor's
professor at the University of California,
Irvine. She's studied attention and stress in
the digital age for over two decades and is also
author of the forthcoming book out on Tuesday,
January 10th. Attention Span, A Groundbreaking Way
to Restore balance, happiness and Productivity.
You can find out more about it at Gloria
markham. Really great having you on. I appreciate
the opportunity to talk about this.
Speaker 4: Thank you for having me.
Speaker 1: So it's almost become cliche now
to repeat some of the things that have been
written many times. There's no really such
thing as multitasking. What you're doing is
quickly switching between tasks. It's also,
you know, if you want to find opinions that
social media and smartphones are killing
our attention span, you can find it. But
now there's the next layer, which is, hey,
you know, maybe that's not actually true.
When people do these digital detoxes, they
don't really seem to have the benefits. Some
claim you can basically find someone making every
claim at this point in time. So maybe to start,
we can just zoom out a little bit and say over
the time that you have been studying these issues,
are there definitive trends that we can start with
about the impact of modern media, smart phones,
social media on attention, on stress and anxiety?
Speaker 4: Yes, there are. So I've been studying
this empirically for almost two decades
now. Let me very quickly explain how I
study attention. Yeah. So, you know, we started
out using stopwatches and shadowing people. And
every time someone switched their attention or
switched screens, we would note that we then
later switched to computer locking techniques
which are very precise, very objective and
unobtrusive so we can get precise measures of how
long exactly people's attention is on any screen,
whether it's their computer or smartphone. And
we find that over the years people's attention
on any screen has diminished their length of
attention. And in the last five years or so,
we find that has gone down to about 47 seconds
on average. If we look at the midpoint,
it's called the median that we find that half of
all of our observations of the length of attention
is actually less than 40 seconds. 40 seconds is
the median. That means that people switch their
attention very fast. They don't spend a lot
of time on any particular screen. And we know
from when we first started measuring us that
the length of attention spans have gone down.
Speaker 2: Now.
Speaker 1: It sounds like that's a bad thing,
but maybe that's an assumption that we should
actually try to prove in some way, right? I mean,
one one could say, okay, that that's true. That's
what's going on. But it's just a result of the way
that the world is. It doesn't objectively
mean that there is a cost or a negative.
Is there a cost or a negative to that reality?
Speaker 4: Yeah, unfortunately there is a cost
because we find a strong relationship between the
frequency of shifting attention and stress. So
stress goes up as attention is is shifted. Now,
going back to years of laboratory research in
psychology, we know that when people switch
their attention, when they multitask among,
you know, switching among different
tasks, blood pressure goes up. There
is a physiological marker in the body that also
indicates that people are under stress. We also
know that when people are probed with validated
questionnaires about their subjective stress,
their perceived stress also goes up at times
when people are shifting their attention,
multitasking fast. So there is a cost to us.
Speaker 1: When we talk about the stress and
anxiety component, it seems important to
distinguish for two to take one example
to take social media. On the one hand, we
have these aspects of the rapidity with
which you can switch between things
when you're scrolling social media,
the distractive element of picking it up and
looking at it when maybe you should be spending
an hour consecutively working. So that's one
side. We then have the stuff that people like
Jonathan Haidt and others look at more, which
is the effect of the content. And does seeing
people's best moments when you're just sitting
at home in your pajamas and comparing or. Right,
there's the content aspect when it comes to
kids in school, the way that some bullying has
moved into the social media space, these are
two different things. How can we distinguish
the impact of. One from the impact of the other.
Speaker 4: Yeah. So you you would have to do some
controlled studies. So you'd have to basically
give people social media that has positive
content and then give them social media that might
have negative content. And then you look at the
differences. So you're you're controlling that.
And then there's other things you can control too,
such as the length of posts and see what impact
that has. But there's absolutely no question that
social media is it's two sided, right? There's
there's benefits. We can't deny that there are
benefits for young people. They can help. They
can be socially connected to other people,
especially during the pandemic. Right. It was
really a great benefit for a number of people,
not not just young people. But of course, there
is a negative side as well. As you mentioned,
cyberbullying. There is misinformation.
So there is absolutely no question that
there is. You know, it's a double edged sword.
Speaker 1: So if we assume that the majority
of my audience kind of understands the the
guideposts here of the concern and of the
reality of what's going on, let's talk a little
bit about sort of like how, one, what safeguards
or behaviors one can kind of cultivate for for
themselves. Neil Postman in his book Technopolis,
you know, like 30 years ago wrote about whenever
there's a new technology, there's good and there's
bad. The idea of saying, let's only allow the
good through regulation, it rarely works. And
we really just need to kind of think through the
best way to welcome these technologies in total.
Right. And sort of limit limit the damage that
they can do. What should people be doing? Is it,
you know, practically is it you put your phone
in a different room, you set a timer and use
these techniques where you work 25 minutes. I
think it's the Pomodoro technique, 25 minutes
and then a five minute break and then you switch
to something else. And is that is it practical to
think people can really do that regularly?
Speaker 4: Yeah. So first of all,
consider there are individual differences.
So personality absolutely plays a role in
people's ability to self regulate. Some people
are born lucky. They have good, good abilities
for self-regulation. Other people are not
born so lucky. But if you're not born lucky,
there are things you can do to change. People
can develop agency over their behaviors. And if
we draw from the work of a very famous social
psychologist, Albert Bandura, he's found that
people in a number of areas can develop self
efficacy. So with stopping smoking, substance
abuse. And so I believe that it's very possible
for people to have control over their attention.
How can they gain agency? There is different
ways. First of all, you can learn to be more
intentional in your behavior. So we do a lot of
automatic behaviors. For example, we check out our
smartphones, you know, just automatically without
thinking. We check email, we go to social media,
which you can do is you can learn to probe
yourself, to bring your your unconscious actions
to become more conscious. I'm a professional
observer of people when I study them, and
I've learned to become a professional observer of
myself by probing myself, probing the reasons why
I'm doing things. So whenever I have an urge to
go to social media, I recognize that urge. I ask
myself, Will I get value out of being there? Why
do I need to go there? Or am I bored? Am I doing a
hard task right? And anyone can develop the skill
to become an observer of themselves. And once you
recognize reasons for why you're doing things,
you can change, right? And if you go to social
media to take a break, then again, you can probe
yourself and say, Am I still getting value or am I
just getting marginal returns? And if you're just
getting marginal returns, it's time to get back to
work. Let me mention another technique that people
can do is to practice what's called forethought.
Forethought means imagining your future self, and
it could be in the very near future, like at the
end of the day, if you go on social media now, how
is that going to impact your life at 10 p.m. or
midnight? Are you still going to be working on
that deadline or are you going to be relaxing,
have a glass of wine watching your favorite
show? Think ahead. Right. Another technique
that people could do is to maintain
their higher level goal. In their mind,
goals are a great shield against distractions if
because because attention is directed to what our
goals are. And if your goal is that you're going
to work on this deadline and finish it right,
then your attention will be directed to it.
Speaker 1: One of the people I've interviewed
before is Cal Newport, who writes a lot about
carving time out for what he calls deep work. And
of course, at the very minimum, that means you're
not checking your smartphone during this time, but
ideally, also you're limiting other distractions
in other ways. And, you know, we've talked with
him about that. One of the things that seems to
apply in the diet world that may also apply here
is whatever you're doing needs to be sustainable,
it seems like. And that's one of the better
arguments I've read against the total sort of like
social media sabbatical of sorts, which is that
it creates what's really an artificial situation
that that nobody says is going to be the long term
situation and that therefore it might be sort of
of limited value, whereas maybe there's more value
to saying, hey, you know, I know I have a tendency
to do my best deep work in the morning. So from
9 to 11, I'm not even going to have my phone in
the room. And so now I'm at least getting to 11
without any distractions. And then from then on I
will do X, Y or Z that that type of thing. Can you
talk a little bit about is it better to jump right
into modes that are sustainable long term, or do
these short term experiments have their place?
Speaker 4: No, I don't think that realistically
we can think about doing digital detoxes for a
very long time. You know, if if any individual
does a digital detox, essentially it penalizes
themselves because they're cutting themselves off
from important work communications, from family,
from loved ones. And you're right. Absolutely.
It's not sustainable. We we live in a digital
world. The ship has sailed. We can't back away
from it. We can't pull out. So what we need to
do instead is to think of solutions that that can
enable us to live in this world and to maintain
well-being. Now, it turns out that people,
you know, you can't maintain a sustained focus
for a lengthy period just in the same way that
you can't lift weights for an extended period
of time. We use up our mental resources now.
People have peaks of time during the day when
their mental resources are at their utmost.
And for most people, it's mid-to-late morning
and it's mid-afternoon. Mm hmm. If you can become
aware of when your personal peaks of attention
are and you can start with with these times that
I mentioned, then you can gear your work around
those times when your attention is is at its best.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's been super useful for
me were very you know, I used to have a list of
things that I sort of plan to accomplish after
taping my show each day, and I learned that I
would get only to a fraction of that list just
because of sort of like mood and who knows other
things that that maybe I can't necessarily
identify. But I found that the more I plan
to do before filming each day, dramatically more
efficient, dramatically more productive. And so
now I kind of tail I know that if I get to my desk
15 minutes earlier, I'm going to do way more than
if I think of doing that at 3 p.m.. Now I have the
benefit of a job where I'm completely in control
of my schedule. The reality is a lot of people
are squeezing these things in around shift work,
for example, and that becomes very difficult.
Speaker 4: That's right. Absolutely. So. So.
That's right. You know, every person
is different. Everyone has their own
personal rhythm. And you need to gear your work
around what your own personal rhythm is for,
for your attentional resources. And, you
know, for me, I can't start work immediately
when I get up. I need time to ramp up. So
I do easy things. When I start, you know,
I will take care of email or read the news and
then, you know, I'm a little bit geared up and
then I can start diving into doing hard work.
And then I'm at my peak now. You know, people can
discover their peak by, you know, finding out what
your chronotype is. Some people are early type,
some people are late types. It can serve as a
guide at least to get you started, but become
aware of when you start feeling exhausted and the
best thing you can do is pull back, take a break,
get replenished, and then you can go back
in with with a full tank of resources.
Speaker 1: We have been speaking with Dr.
Gloria Mark. The book, which is out on Tuesday,
January 10th. Is Attention Span a
groundbreaking way to Restore balance,
happiness and productivity. Productivity. You can
find out more at W WW dot Gloria markham really
appreciate your time and your insights today.
Speaker 4: Oh thank you so much for having me.
Speaker 1: All right. Let's look
at a few other things that happened
yesterday. George Santos seemed to forget his own
name on the floor of the house multiple times. His
name was called for a vote on Speaker of the House
on the fifth ballot. He seems not to recognize his
own name, which is just funny because, of
course, his full name is George Anthony Devil
there Santos. And it raises a question of whether
does he even really go by George Santos? Normally,
maybe he goes by Anthony Duvall there or George
Duvall there or Anthony Sanders. I don't know. But
here he is. They call him multiple times. Doesn't
seem to recognize they're calling him for a vote.
The guy to his right seems to tell
him like, hey, that's your name, sir.
Speaker 4: Santos. Santos.
Speaker 1: SARBANES okay. And
they move on to Sarbanes, and then he holds up his
hand and yells out that he's voting for McCarthy.
Speaker 2: Jeffries You even.
Speaker 1: You even see Matt
Gates come by. Just kind of like, what
is it that is even going on here? So just
kind of weird. Everything about Santos is strange.
For all we know, he's used to being called some
other name. I don't know. And it seems that he is
continuing to struggle to sort of build community
in the House of Representatives. And I don't
really know the end game for Santos. The
first 48 hours are not sustainable. Running away
with a huge backpack, running away from reporters
who want to ask him questions. Sitting by himself
in the floor of the house, picking his nose, not
recognizing his own name. And it's all
just truly bizarre. But I also have kind
of like a morbid curiosity where, like, how how
awkward can this possibly get? And you all know, I
love awkward. So we're going ahead and going to
go ahead and follow that. And by the way, the lies
from Jorge Santos haven't stopped since he arrived
in Washington, D.C. Let's talk about that next.